[Musique]
dans les assiettes tant appris qu'on
dise aux genoux japauto - pourquoi tu as
pris tout ça alors
parce que c'est gratos le all inclusive
c'est de voir la maman cousin conseils
de vieil propres première buffet
premiers transats pour les boissons
on mélange mais moi de zombies coco
lebrun à kerhall quand deux tiers d'eau
ok alors quatre bras olindo vive il faut
mettre le paquet sur les animations
je ne veux pas voir un mot qui
s'ennuient un mot qui s'éclate c'est un
bon mot qui va bien et un moment qui va
bien c'est un bon mot qui revient km à
damas
on se serait pas déjà croisé quelque
part tous les clubs
peut-être non
[Musique]
je le dis comme ça en passant je suis
retraité il veut donc libre rêve
bon à savoir traverser j'ai perdu mon
baluchon c'est la cata mon baluchon
servat le chou un ballon chaud en forme
de ballons chauds kabanov une pendule
pour 3 bagnole de tisha ma mère dans le
baluchon brno
tam est elle morte un porno oui nos
mamans n'ont jamais tu fais quoi là jess
pana clock est d'accord c'est le grand
carnaval
[Musique]